February 24th, 2022. Putin launches a war
to prevent NATO expansion. Today,
NATO's border with Russia is twice as
long. This might be the most
spectacular strategic failure
in modern history, and it all started
with a lie about the conversation that
happened 32 years ago.
I'm going to show you exactly what the
conversation actually said, and why
Putin's entire justification
for this war falls apart when you read
the real documents.
Here's the story that's been
repeated for decades, and it sounds
completely reasonable.
February 1990, James Baker, US
Secretary of State, meets with Gorbachev
in Moscow. The Soviet
Union is collapsing.
Baker promises NATO will never expand,
not one inch eastward.
Fast forward 30 years,
NATO has expanded to Russia's border.
Putin feels betrayed and
surrounded. The Ukraine invasion
is his desperate attempt to stop what he
sees as Western aggression.
Putin himself has cited this
promise dozens of times. Russian media
repeats it constantly. Even
some Western analysts accept it
as fact. There's just one problem, it's
not what happened. Yale
historian M.E.  Sarotte spent years
getting over 1,000 documents declassified
from six different National
Archives. When you actually
read what Baker said to Gorbachev, the
entire narrative collapses.
Here's Baker's exact words
from the German Federal Archives,
February 9th, 1990. Would you prefer a
unified Germany outside
of NATO, or tied to NATO with assurances
that NATO's jurisdiction
would not shift one inch eastward
from its present position? Notice what's
missing. Baker isn't
talking about Poland, Ukraine, or
Eastern Europe. He's talking about East
German territory during German
reunification. But here's
the part that destroys Putin's entire
argument. Three months
later, when Gorbachev actually
complains about possible NATO expansion
to other countries,
President Bush gives him a completely
different answer. Bush says any country
has a right to choose a
different path. Think about that.
Bush wasn't promising to limit NATO
expansion. He was establishing the
principle that any country
could join. The Soviet advisors in the
room were furious. They knew
Gorbachev had just agreed to
the legal framework that would allow
unlimited NATO expansion. And that's
exactly what happened.
But here's what makes Putin's betrayal
story even more
ridiculous. Throughout the 1990s,
while NATO was expanding, Russia wasn't
fighting it. They
were partnering with it.
1992, Russia joins NATO's new Cooperation
Council as a founding member.
1994, Russia participates in NATO's
Partnership for Peace program.
1997, Russia signs an official agreement
with NATO and gets a
permanent desk at NATO headquarters.
For years, Russian and NATO forces were
literally doing joint
military exercises together. Gazprom
was becoming Europe's biggest energy
supplier. If NATO
expansion was really an existential
threat to Russia, why were they helping
to make it happen? The
answer is simple. Because the real
story isn't about NATO expansion. It's
about something much
more personal to Putin.
Let's talk about what really scares
Putin. Ukrainian choice.
2019, Ukrainian elections. Far-right
parties got 2% of the
vote. For comparison,
France's far-right got 33%. Germany's got
12%. After Russian aggression in 2014,
Ukraine's parliament votes 334 to 0 for
NATO membership. Picture this,
your grandparents survived Stalin's
famine, your parents
lived under Soviet repression,
you finally get to choose. Of course you
choose the West. That's
not Western manipulation,
that's survival instinct. Putin's not
afraid of NATO missiles.
He's afraid Ukrainian democracy
will give Russians ideas. So let's get
back to Putin's
strategic genius. December 2021,
Putin demands NATO return to 1997
borders. The West says no.
February 2022, Putin invades to
prevent NATO expansion. Result, Finland
and Sweden, neutral for decades,
immediately join NATO.
Russia's border with NATO more than
doubles overnight. Every
single action Putin took to
prevent NATO expansion guaranteed more
NATO expansion. So next
time someone tells you NATO
expansion caused this war, ask them one
simple question. How
exactly did Putin's war to stop
NATO expansion end up creating the
longest NATO border in
Russian history? Let me know in the
comments if this changed how you think
about the conflict. And if
you want more videos that cut
through geopolitical myths with actual
evidence, hit subscribe. Because there's
a lot more propaganda
to debunk. The documents don't lie. The
question is whether
we're ready to believe them.